My name is Patience Thomson,
born Bragg.
I was the youngest child of
William Lawrence Bragg and the
granddaughter of WH Bragg, whom
I just dimly remember.
We have this bust of
my father, which
I absolutely love.
It's a very, very
good likeness.
It moves and stirs me
every time I see it.
William Henry and William
Lawrence Bragg were the first
father and son team to win a
Nobel Prize for a discovery
that shone a new light on the
structure of our world.
And it all started
with an x-ray.
Most people know what an x-ray
is, or they think of the
shadowy photograph that they've
seen of a broken leg
or a broken arm.
So they know that x-rays is a
powerful special type of light
and that it can pass through
most forms of matter and
certainly can pass through
biological tissue.
But it's absorbed by
bone, which is
why it leaves a shadow.
In 1912, Max von Laue was
firing x-rays at crystal
samples and becoming
intrigued by the
patterns that were formed.
But he couldn't make complete
sense of what they meant.
WH Bragg showed his
son Lawrence
these diffraction patterns.
Well, like everybody else, he
saw a pattern of spots.
But I think he also saw a
puzzle, and a puzzle that
needed to be solved.
He loved detective stories.
That was his great thing.
One of his great mortifications
is that he once
sat next to Agatha Christie at
dinner and was introduced by
her married name and didn't
realise who she was.
My mother said afterwards, you
must have had a marvellous
time sitting next to
Agatha Christie.
And he said, what?
OK.
So maybe Lawrence wouldn't have
made a great detective.
But when it came to piecing
together scientific clues, it
was a different matter.
He just looked at the problem in
a completely different way
to Laue, and he saw what
the solution was.
He noticed things that other
people didn't notice.
Everybody was looking at those
Laue x-rays and trying to get
an interpretation.
Typical of my father to
see that, in fact, a
two-dimensional sheet could
be transformed into a
three-dimensional model.
Ping pong balls and rods.
This is one of the very first
diffraction patterns that the
Braggs themselves would
have taken.
And it's taken from
a crystal of salt.
You can see the very
particular pattern.
Each of these spots represents
the end of a diffracted ray.
And it was their particular
insight that showed us how to
interpret this pattern in terms
of the atomic structure
within the crystal.
William Henry had been thinking
of x-rays as particles.
However, Lawrence suddenly had
an insight about the nature of
crystals themselves.
So what is it really that
makes a thing a crystal?
It's its inside arrangement.
It's the fact that the molecules
or atoms in it are
in an absolutely regular
pattern, like soldiers on
parade or like the pattern
of a wallpaper.
The atoms are arranged in layers
or in two-dimensional
planes that go all the way
through the crystal.
And so he realised that each
one of these acts like a
semi-transparent mirror.
What's happening is that the
x-ray is reflecting off the
top layer but also off the next
layer underneath and off
the layer underneath that, and
the x-rays bounce off those
planes in all sorts
of directions.
By thinking of the problem
simply as reflection, he was
able to figure out how the atoms
were arranged exactly
and produce this model in fact,
which is the very first
atomic structure of a
crystalline sample that was
ever solved.
He liked to make connections.
He liked always to
be building up a
picture increasing insight.
Scientists finally had the
ability to look at the atomic
structure of matter.
And they could start to
understand some of the
physical properties of matter,
in terms of the underlying
atomic structure.
And that was an enormous
breakthrough.
He didn't realise probably at
that stage how massive the
breakthrough he'd just
made had been.
His solution was almost
always the simplest.
The same in his watercolours,
with the almost professional
ability to bring out the
important things.
And the same in his articles.
He would give visual
illustrations.
It wasn't tell me.
It was show me.
And it helped to explain why it
is that these two forms of
carbon have such different
properties.
Diamond is one of the hardest
substances that we know of.
And the atomic structure shows
that that strength arises
because the atoms are bonded to
each other very closely and
in all three directions.
Whereas in graphite,
you've got these
close hexagonal nets.
But the whole structure is
layered, and they can slide
easy past one another.
Graphite is also a pure
form of carbon,
but it's much softer.
That very softness arises from
the fact that these layers are
not tightly bonded
to one another.
And that was first revealed
by x-ray crystallography.
Well, the great, great
breakthrough on
crystallography came when he was
walking along The Backs in
Cambridge and suddenly had
a blinding insight.
But it could be when he was
doing the washing up.
He didn't have to be in a
rarefied atmosphere to have
these ideas.
You felt that his brain was
working all the time and that
he liked to have some problem
to crunch on.
The Braggs' work on
crystallography was disrupted
during World War I, with Henry
moving into submarine
detection and Lawrence being
sent to the front line.
But their insights led to a
shared Nobel Prize in 1915,
with Lawrence becoming the
youngest Nobel winner in
history at just 25.
My father heard that he had won
the Nobel Prize when he
was in the trenches.
He was obviously extremely
chuffed and pleased, but I
think the world was in such
total disarray around him that
it all must have seemed
rather remote.
He now turned to using science
to fight against the German
Army's superior weaponry.
The German Army had the upper
hand very often, because they
had much more powerful guns.
And my father was asked to
establish a system of working
out, by listening to the sounds
and comparing how long
it took them to get to various
different points, exactly
where the location
of the guns were.
In the obituaries on my father,
it did say that his
team shortened the war, because
they, could put the
enemy guns out of action.
Back in peace time, the field of
x-ray crystallography went
from strength to strength.
The discoveries by the Braggs
and their successors kept
coming, and the technique was
used to solve increasingly
complex structures, such as
graphite, penicillin, DNA,
and, more recently,
whole viruses.
To date, crystallography
has been a
feature of 29 Nobel Prizes.
The application of this
technique transformed our
understanding of matter in so
many different fields, not
just in geology, understanding
minerals, but in chemistry
understanding how different
chemicals are built up, and
then, finally, brought us into
the realm of biology, where we
could figure out how it is that
the molecules that exist
within us are coordinated and
work together in order to
sustain life.
And these days, it's kind of a
shame he's not with us now,
because I think he would just be
enormously impressed to see
how the technique has developed
even since 1971,
just the size and the scale and
ambition of the types of
problems that people
are tackling now.
Whole virus particles have been
crystallised and solved.
We are simply getting better
and better at doing
crystallography.
The Curiosity Rover that NASA
sent to Mars last year has got
an x-ray diffraction instrument
on the Rover that's
trundling over the surface.
And so it can pick up samples
of soil, and it can analyse
the minerals that are
in the soil on Mars.
He liked Agatha Christie, I
think, because in the last
chapter everything
falls into place.
He liked neat endings.
They're still winning Nobel
Prizes, and I don't see that
slowing down.